[Music]
new suit yeah real cool you clearly
don't mean that all black cape I mean
where do you get these super ideas okay
I didn't steal this from you if that's
what you're implying why stop there why
not drive my car sleep in my Mansion get
tipsy and tongue kiss my
butler you you just I know what I said
hey I have things to do let me just cut
to the quick okay okay no good company
has two CEOs I think we need to
crystallize the leadership of the
Justice League okay the quickest way to
do that is to can your ass can my ass
like sardines [__] okay here's the
thing Bruce if someone should step down
it should be you you you're dressed like
a bat I am a bat no you're not you're
not a bat you're a scared little boy
playing dress up distracting the
grown-ups with actual Powers who were
trying to deal with actual problems I
help really yes remember when we fought
those parad demons they were tough and I
totally took down one of them oh please
the only reason you knocked out that
pair of demon was because I held it down
like a dad who takes a few cracks at a
pinata so his son can hit it once knock
out the candy and feel like a big boy
that's why Alfred always preh hits the
pinata you're
useless eat [__] [__] wad good come
back hope starts with an age I used up
all my best stuff last time it's time
you packed up your stuff and left Bruce
okay hold on um let's uh walk this back
instead of you being fired or me being
fired how
about co- leaders Musk one and musk 2
you can own Twitter I'll make battery
cars you sure because it felt like you
brought me in here to fire me oh come
on I you don't know me by now I was
joshing let's commemorate our new
partnership and we'll uh we'll just have
ourselves a little toast what do you say
happy to hear it
okay
cheers these wouldn't Kryptonite cubes
would they Cal look I know you have
trust issues your parents put you in
like a yeast infection pill and send you
to our planet but you can trust me this
is not Kryptonite this is this is green
tea from Asia from Asia green tea from
Asia where in Asia Asia Miner I if if
it's so good you drink
first I would and you're from Krypton so
you don't know this but the custom is
that the guest drinks the green tea from
Asia first drink first so you drink
first please you drink
first okay all right you know I am a
little thirsty so here I go drinking the
normal
tea I don't want to be offensive but
it's not good to my palet yeah you're
fired Bruce hold on look look you in
you're the boss but before I go I was
wondering if you could help me with one
small thing you're so
strong could you help me open this
innocent jar of
pickles what kind of pickles are
those I'd say Jewish they look like
Kryptonite no no no no those these are
these are these are these are Crypton
not brand pickles you know when you're
trying to lie it's best not to call it
basically the exact same word no taken
but uh one last thing quick question you
you want to put your hand in this Shrek
puppet it will not wither you like an
old man I'm not going to put my hand in
the glowing green Shrek puppet Bruce
come on it'll be fun you can be like Oh
I'm an ogre I live in a swamp H now your
Rockstar get your game on good PID H now
your Rockstar get your game on get L
Batman sorry I fell in one of my Shrek
holes the last one lasted the entire
quarantine this is getting Beyond stupid
you have the rest of the day to pack up
your stuff and leave the Hall of Justice
hold it hold this
rock
really just hold this rock you're not
even trying anymore look at it it's
Rocky and very
holdable you could hold
it you see me I'm on the Rock puts an
itch in your
brain nothing's going to scratch that
itch like whole
deck I want you to visualize something
in your
mind it's
you you look down in your
hand there's something in
it it's this
rug so [__] sad go play with your
Gadgets in your Legos you
toddler what a
farquad
[Music]